في كل المعارك القتال من الجو يكون فعالا
لبسط السيطره على الارض الجيش السوداني
لجا الى هذا السلاح لمنازله قوات الدعم
السريع اسطول القوات الجويه السودانيه
يعتمد بشكل اساسي على عشر مقاتلات من طراز
29 طائره تمنح الجيش نقطه تفوق بالنظر الى
ميزاتها المختلفه فهي مرنه تطلق صواريخ جو
ارض مقاتله تعتبر ردا تقنيا وعسكريا روسيا
على طائره اف 16 الامريكيه الجيش السوداني
يضم مجموعه اخرى من الطائرات سوفياتيه
الروسيه الصنع منها سبع طائرات من فئتي
ميج 21 وميك 23 اضافه الى سبعه عشره
مقاتله صخور من فئتي
24.25
ومقاتلات خفيفه من طراز جي 7
كيو 5 من الصين واخرى متعدده المهام من
الجيل الثالث من طراز اف من الولايات
المتحده القوه الجويه السودانيه سبق
واعلنت عن نجاحها في دمج الطائرات
المقاتله من الولايات المتحده والصين
وروسيا في شبكه واحده لتبادل البيانات في
العام 2018
حصيله القوات الجويه السودانيه من
الهليكوبتر المقاتله تصل الى 43 طائره من
نوع ميل ميلي اربعه وعشرين صاحبه التصميم
الكلاسيكي اضافه الى ثلاث طائرات هليكوبتر
نقل من الفئه 17 وكذلك 24 طائره من فئه من
ثمانيه في السودان ثمان قواعد جويه ابرزها
قاعده مروي العسكريه الواقعه بولايه شمال
السودان قاعده شهدت مواجهات داريه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في بدايه الصراع
وقاعده وادي سيدنا في ام درمان فضلا عن
قاعده الابيض في شمال ولايه كوردوفان ثم
قاعده الخرطوم وسط العاصمه
ومع استمرار المواجهات تستعد الولايات
المتحده لفرض عقوبات جديده على افراد
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع عقوبات تعيد
الى الاذهان تلك التي كانت مفروضه ايام
حكم الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير بلال
البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات